look out there out there is the perfect  lap you see it I think so  most people can't Carroll Shelby  maybe Lee Iacocca Ford Motor suppose  henry ford ii wanted to build the  greatest race car the world's ever seen  to win the 24 Hours of LeMans what's it  take I'll take something money can't buy  he can buy speed what in about speed you  need a pure racer behind a wheeler car  that's ten miles I don't trust him an  inch we heard he's difficult no no Ken's  a puppy dog  now whatever it is she'll know trust me  you're gonna build a car to beat Ferrari  with a correct and how long did you tell  her that you needed to 300 years it's 90  days  this isn't the first time Ford Motors  gone to war we know how to do more than  push paper  go ahead girl go to war thank you sir  do you think you can beat Ferrari  lighter faster  that don't work for nastier  we're gonna make history  you ready I was born ready mr. Shelby  hit it  [Laughter]  [Applause]  you